confere aí pessoal é que com isso ele
está aqui hoje 1º por poder conversar
com vocês esse projeto e além disso
sobretudo porque estamos em uma escola
eu sou professor eu acho que se a gente
tem nosso tema é pessoas que votou mundo
sem lugar que tem só festa pra gente
poder mudar o mundo ela se esforça é
aqui nessa em todas as outras escolas
que a gente começa a criar e desenvolver
o ambiente mais adequado para criar
pessoas que efetivamente vai mudar o
mundo e esse projeto nasceu de uma
escola uma das atualmente em 591 escolas
que a gente tem na resenhar no país
inteiro
essa aqui pertinho foi a primeira escola
será que a gente já viu aqui na cidade
de são paulo no bairro da liberdade aqui
na outra ponta da avenida paulista onde
alguns dos nossos alunos cerca de 30
deles aceitar o desafio de conversar em
inglês com os senhores e senhoras fla
nos estados unidos sobre assuntos
diversos
com o comando com o conhecimento que
eles tinham do idioma nativo desses
senhores e senhoras exclusivamente para
poder trocar experiências trocar
conhecimento não havia uma lição a ser
completada uma tarefa valendo nota uma
obrigação a ser feita mas pura e
simplesmente o desejo de conhecer de
trocar experiências por pela dos nossos
alunos
talvez a vontade ou desejo de se
comunicar no idioma estrangeiro
nesse caso o inglês pelo lado dos quais
600 deles lá do outro lado daquela tela
senhores e senhoras o desejo de ter
companhia e de conhecer pessoas novas e
foi assim que uma idéia tão simples que
na seus pequenos diante de algo que nos
surpreendeu
naquele momento foi com uma idéia tão
simples poderia ter um resultado tão
grandioso que eu vou contar pra vocês
daqui a pouco mas diz contar os
resultados
acredito que alguns de vocês já tenham
conhecido vídeo mas com tal resultado
para mostrar pra vocês um pedacinho de
um vídeo criado pela nossa agência é cb
brasil mostrando um pouco desse projeto
então vamos ver o vídeo esse documento
com vocês falam
ó
na orla vai ser entrar porque tinha de
driblar a elite intelectual genéricas
shopping de luxo
moral excelente foi igual a esses
pequenos explica que embora ovos é assim
aos céus rock no mma nomeou uma violenta
we need to é conectar os seguintes
muitos chineses 1.100 e evitarem
rompê-lo chamada nessa faixa externa sem
êxito que o brasil manda na pt a chegada
do dorival foi mal e kuyt a canon em
junho esse senhor deve nós nem maio ai
ai ai ai um gol aqui e aqui
o flash de sines existentes a corte
explica selma net o gol do brasil água
mmartan a iffhs tema house eo ano da
fifa dias 1º e 8 bateu em s
é ótimo tem que o fórum distingue a fesp
ensinou que olhem carimbo aportaram eo
amanhã em 2009 o url blog
by
isso é uma mostra do projeto que nasceu
como eu disse é uma idéia muito simples
capitaneado em parceria e eu acredito
fortemente por falar em parceria que são
essas idéias que são simples e as que
nascem se desenvolvem e coletivamente
aquelas que efetivamente são capazes de
mudar o mundo
a claudia também que responder isso
falou que mais cedo daí de quem tem
sonhos de que efetivamente acredita
neles dias quando se combina com a ação
e disse nós estamos falando
o projeto surgiu como eu disse é uma
parceria entre o cna ea nossa agência de
publicidade fcb brasil no sentido de
termos as pessoas ea tecnologia isso foi
criado pelas nossas lideranças pelo cna
pela minha inscrição minha colega
luciana fortuna diretora de marketing
com sentadinha ali que acreditou nisso
que nós somos
convidamos esses nossos alunos aqui você
tem a liberdade junto com esses senhores
e senhoras daquela casa de repouso que
vocês viram lá em chicago foram 12
desses senhores e senhoras conquista dos
nossos alunos de diferentes níveis que
aceitaram este desafio
e aí como vocês puderam perceber
existiam várias situações que eu contra
aquelas nossas crenças arraigadas uma
delas vocês podem ter percebido é a
questão de que a gente precisa ter a
comunicação perfeita para que as coisas
possam vir a acontecer em termos de
comunicação
isso não faz parte das nossas crenças
nós trabalhamos sonhar com a abordagem
comunicativa então a gente entende que
mais importante do que saber todas as
estruturas e toda a gramática
corretamente a gente acredita que antes
disso vem a comunicação que grava
acho que ela vem como suporte a isso a
chegar à comunicação absolutamente
perfeita assim falha que é importante
mas não é a primeira força exemplo do
que estou falando
aquela senhora que corrija minha
qualidade do irmão você prestar atenção
nisso que ele fala que ela fala que o
irmão tem um jeito brasileiro ela para
que o irmão tem 23 anos agrada rastrear
e destruir aquela senhora com uma
delicadeza com carinho com cuidado
incríveis disse
em vez de dizer isso você poderia dizer
você poderia tentar dizer que reestrou
entre tui e os call
então nesse sentido ela faz a correção
entendendo a intenção comunicativa da
menina
nesse sentido uma outra também nesse
sentido ela coloca a intenção corrigido
de uma forma muito cuidadosa como tem
também um outro caso de uma outra menina
que disse que o primeiro destino delas
seria os estados unidos
ela não sabia dizer dessa mancha na
décima em que em português a gente tem a
mesma palavra ea outra foi além de um
outro patente de pronúncia e por fim a
moça falar a palavra improvável que é
melhorar então ela fala foi pedra ainda
as que a estrutura que ela consegue ir
àquela senhora que quer que responde diz
que ela está indo muito bem
ou seja entende a intenção comunicativa
dela
veja era uma noite ela está em um nível
avançado ela está no processo de
aprendizagem então isso acaba mostrando
pra gente que apesar de a gente ter as
muitas vezes
apesar de a gente tem muitas vezes o
desejo de saber falar que o
absolutamente absoluta perfeição antes
de se comunicar
a gente pode muitas vezes tentar fazer
isso como um processo e perceber que a
gente já está mais adiante do que a
gente imagina
essa é uma daquelas mensagens que esse
projeto nos trouxe uma das aprendizagens
que ele nos mostrou outra coisa que a
gente pode perceber é que a gente tem
para inscrições
nesse projeto até agora ele é replicado
a gente vai levá lo adiante mas essas
lições nos ensinaram estamos ensinando a
levá los adiante de uma forma mais
refinada talvez o convite que eu quero
fazer para vocês nessa fala de hoje ao
assistir isso ea pensar em fazer coisas
parecidas
tem a ver com isso porque isso teve uma
repercussão muito maior do que aquela
que a gente imaginava para contar pra
vocês
primeiro que esse vídeo foi colocado
numa quinta feira à noite
enfim a gente ficou sabendo depois que
ele foi para um outro caminho que teve
repercussão em diversos países do mundo
a primeira 1º t nos estados unidos e
depois ele foi detido em programas de tv
aqui e fora daqui inteiros de
personalidades e 770 para muito além do
que aquilo que a gente imaginava
e porquê porque conforme a gente ouviu
de uma dessas personalidades
o mundo tem nos mostrado coisas tão
cruéis e tem ganho e essas coisas mais
tempo tal repercussão que quando algo
disso acontece a ressonância que isso
tem mostra que a gente está com uma
certa fome uma certa seç de coisas um
pouco mais bonitas e mais carinhosas
como essas que a gente tem isso aqui não
só esse projeto como os anteriores
essa foi uma das lições que a gente
aprendeu outra das missões que a gente
aprendeu é que coisas boas têm
reconhecimento sim apesar de tanta coisa
ruim peso ter nos mostrado diferente
disso
por exemplo esse vídeo especificamente
esse vídeo num projecto por si só mas
esse livro especificamente foi premiado
com dez leões no festival de cannes na
frança de publicidade três de ouro três
de prata e quatro de bronze obra se
conhece né
enfim além de outros prêmios e menções
que a gente recebeu ao longo do tempo
sem contar todas as demais menções e
prêmios e elogios que a gente percebeu
desde que desde então desde aquela época
essa foi uma das lições que a gente
aprendeu outra delas foi aprender a
começar a pensar em coisas de forma
diferente daquilo que a gente está
acostumado a ouvir e de tanto ouvir
passaram a achar que são verdades quando
não necessariamente são uma delas que a
gente ouve estando aqui nesta escola que
trabalha com jovens o tempo todo a gente
pode começar a pensar que o jovem vocês
me perdoará a proeza da fala jovem não
tem paciência com velho não é isso que a
gente o tempo todo especialmente na
nossa cultura brasileira como a gente
pode ver não é verdade
vários desses jovens voltaram a falar
com os mesmos senhores e senhoras ou não
e essa troca de experiências conforme
colocado por um desses alunos foi uma
das coisas mais ricas e eu tive a
oportunidade de falar com uma delas
uma das senhoras e foi essa a minha
mensagem para nós passou o primeiro não
é necessariamente verdade que jovens não
têm paciência com velhos
muito pelo contrário há espaço para esse
tipo de interação entre gerações que a
gente muitas vezes acha que não a acha
que é desprezível
outra coisa velho não mexe com
tecnologia não consegue não tem como
também não é verdade
a tecnologia aqui é um instrumento para
a integração de pessoas que não se
encontrariam de outra forma a não ser
que efetivamente cresceu aceite o
convite do rapazinho né
então isso também é algo pra gente
considerar as nossas falas que a
tecnologia é sim um instrumento de que
pode ser comum ao cotidiano de pessoas
de mais idade e que a gente não precisa
partir do principio a vu avó deixa a
senhora não vai entender o senhor não
vai entender isso não é verdade o fato
de o ritmo de aprendizagem de pessoas
mais velhas e diferentes não significa
que eles são incapazes de aprender
o amor é são lar mais uma lição que a
gente aprendeu com isso uma terceira
lição não raro a gente ouve dizer das
pessoas mais resistentes à tecnologia ou
que têm visão mais
crítica é que a tecnologia afasta as
pessoas pode afastar mas também pode
aproximar a gente viu aqui é que a
tecnologia foi usada para aproximar
pessoas que poderiam nunca se conhecer
na vida então é mais uma daquelas
falácias que nesse vídeo nos permitiu
que esse projeto nos permitiu refletir e
pensar novamente a tecnologia pode sim
afastar as pessoas
ou pode aproximá-los depende de como a
gente quiser usar mais uma reflexão
possível mais uma lição que a gente pode
aprender a outra delas é que aprender
idiomas pode ser sim uma forma de pode
ser um processo longo prazo e uma forma
difícil de que as pessoas adquiram uma
outra outro universo de conhecimento ou
não como a gente pode ver aqui a
aplicação foi feita de forma imediata
para esses alunos e eles que elas já
puderam que está imediatamente aquilo
que estavam aprendendo com pessoas que
efetivamente eram nativas e o mais rico
disso tudo que foi colocado pelos
próprios participantes
a questão da ampliação de visão de mundo
de experiências o que o vídeo não deixa
muito claro mas quem viu pode
experimentar aqui pela própria
ferramenta quando as pessoas escolhiam
os participantes e tudo aqui no canto da
tela havia assuntos sugeridos família
a geografia sei lá não me lembro
exatamente quais eram os assuntos mas
não seriam sujeitos aqui em baixo e eles
foram absolutamente ignorada pelos pelo
país das participantes na maior parte
das vezes porque eles porque eles
queriam falar efetivamente era de si
próprios e daquelas coisas que fizeram
caras como vocês viram por aquele senhor
que mostrou a foto de si e da sua esposa
quando mais jovens ou seja a troca de
experiências uma daquelas senhoras disse
que antes de falar com aquela menina a
única imagem que já tinha do brasil era
de uma estátua de jesus cristo com os
braços abertos e que depois dessa
então ela passou a saber mais sobre o
brasil e teve curiosidade de conhecer
mais sobre esse país e que ela falou
muito sobre chicago eo museu de arte ea
cidade bela pra essa menina e acabou
tendo mais contato com essa menina do
que com os próprios filhos que moram nos
estados unidos e por último a última
lição que a gente aprendeu o que eu
prometo saber disso tudo é que apesar da
tecnologia apesar dos séculos
apesar das mudanças todas certas coisas
não mudam são aquelas coisas que nos
fazem humanos dentre elas a de que
jovens aprendem com as gerações que
virão antes de adquiri independentemente
da idade precisamos das companhias dos
outros e que é essa interação inclusive
com a tecnologia que faz com que o nosso
universo se espantam e com que sejamos
humanos e é assim que a gente vai
transformando o mundo
muito obrigado